Тут, біля підніжжя
Кавказьких гір, рукою подати до кордону
Грузії та Росії.
Історики вважають, що вино тут виготовляють
вже вісім тисяч років.
Нині вино - третя за обсягом стаття
національного експорту.
Традиційно грузинські вина зберігали не в дерев’яних
чи сталевих, а у глиняних бочках.
Так продовжуть робити й нині.
Щоправда, лише для вищого сегменту ринку.
Компанія з німецьким капіталом «Schuchmann Wines»
розливає майже півтора мільйона
пляшок вина на рік. Дев’яносто відсотків
іде на експорт.
Ці ящики - 600 пляшок сапераві,
вони вже готові для експорту.
Це вино поїде в Китай- через Казахстан.
З переходом на стандарти ЄС для грузинських
виноробів відкрилося багато дверей –
і не лише в Європу.
Інші країни також звернули увагу
на грузинське вино.
Але що дає угода про вільну торгівлю
з ЄС на практиці, у щоденному бізнесі?
Долати кордони стало легше, вони стали відкритішими.
Вести бізнес з європейськими країнами стало
значно краще.
Тепер одні стандарти, одна документація,
ті ж самі папери.
Після розвалу Радянського Союзу рівень життя
в Грузії пішов у піке.
Конфлікт з Росією – найбільшим ринком збуту
для Грузії – разом з політичною
нестабільністю мали катастрофічний
ефект. До цього слід ще додати
географічне розсташування Грузії -
за тисячі кілометрів
від країн ЄЄ. Тож не дивно,
що в Грузїі такий високий рівень
безробіття.
Проте недолік географічного росташування нині перетворився
на перевагу – відколи Грузія
стала таким собі хабом для регіону
та ворітьми у ЄС
для третіх країн.
Інвестиції в Грузії дуже вигідні для Китаю, адже
грузинську продукцію можна без жодних мит
експортувати в Євросоюз.
Для ЄС це також вигідно,
бо в Грузії дуже дешева робоча сила,
тож європейським компаніям
вигідно інвестувати у виробництво
на території Грузії і потім
експортувати продукцію назад
у свої країни.
Говорити про Грузію як про новий Сингапур на Кавказі
поки зарано, проте
залізниця, яка з’єднає її з Китаєм через країни Середньої Азії,
та будівництво міжнародного морського порту
Анаклія можуть відродити славу
Грузії як центру
євразійської торгівлі.